Comcast 60 minutes these are tough if
only this movie is over two hours long
also Universal really doesn't want me to
slam them for X seconds of logos but
sticking the narration over the logos is
still a sin right I don't even know what
to call that logo eration
narrow logos the weak and strong ever
more powerful America she's got more
double-sided tape on that scarf than
Miley used on SNL would've transformers
were entire cities green light are you a
studio president though dude no just my
fellow stoner friend literally does not
matter bro this movies getting made
super unfair odds
it's like Eminem challenging me to a rap
battle this is godzilla vs bambi right
here
so how exactly does this work the city
is laid out normally but then when they
need to move and all folds in on itself
to make it easier for transportation
fine but we're now all the people go and
how would you know for certain
everyone is out of a building when it
begins transforming I get that people
should know better but let's face it
most don't so how many people get
crushed every time this has to happen
Wow Hugo Weaving turned down an infinity
war because he was making this instead
small Bavarian mining town powered by C
20 land engines barely enough fuel to
last us a week I was there enough fuel
in the world they get the predator
cities through a day my SUV gets 19
miles to the gallon if I'm lucky so what
would this get negative 5
honestly seen better CGI and the
openings of civilization games they
kinda known as enter the silos all of
them drop all our food so we can escape
and we'll deal with starvation later
maneuver this movie thinks it's
steampunk Mad Max Wild Wild West entire
city edition I know there are so many
ways I could go with this in but
honestly the stupid money made from the
minions is probably what got this pile
greenlit so the DD angle in a weird way
checks out he'd be everything you have
if he's been giving you less than
everything until now his ass should be
fired and maybe behead it this works oh
no after several minutes of bouncing and
plowing through hills and rock and dirt
something finally broke tight the shot
you mean they could have done this the
whole fucking time y'all ready on your
this is your last in this universe
baseball players get four strikes and
games are now over six hours long even I
know not to trust the writings of anyone
named Nimrod luckily I thought my man
Matthew there um this is wrong unless
Matthew has advanced and speaks English
and consented this otherwise it's
torture right this is what I wanted to
show you the opening credits of an 80s
sitcom kunai society so advanced so
scientific be so stupid thing I wonder
aloud every day in real life somehow
makes it into the movie we come across
dangerous tech it's in way better
condition in this junk all the time now
I've noticed the pieces have started to
go missing so he knew to close the door
for privacy but spat out the sensitive
information before he closed the door
the hell you'll just just give me from
the lower tiers with no family and no
prospects if there's one thing you can
count on from dystopian post-apocalyptic
teen fiction it's a harsh social class
system also Skippy from the lower tiers
was my college girlfriend's favorite
position I found like the gut workers
shovel everything into the furnaces
well they care about is feeding the
beast isn't that what everyone should
care about fuel keeps the city on wheels
moving but not the fuel they would just
be well a normal city on the ground why
are we moving these cities around like
this again well as long as you warn them
in advance I'm sure they'll be okay with
it I read all your books I read your
books cliche yes this is an official
cliche you can blame Hunt for Red
October Jurassic Park 3 goosebumps and
more that is a fusion and flashes so oh
that plane fire
the universal accounting teams words of
warning about this film made it into the
script even money he only sees her
because of the bright red scarf which
stands out and the place where everyone
else wears grayscale clothing this is
for my mother this is for Pandora
why not Spotify Hobbs or iTunes Toretto
no one stops her
Oh God forever dude she survives the
chainsaws galore also chainsaw school or
is a the name of my Tim the tool man
Taylor inspired metal band in the 90s
Pete the only sex move I could ever get
my college girlfriend off with see a
spicy Albanian Cola drink or deep the
in-store nickname for Home Depot's
annual power tool sale cuz this a movie
or a goddamn video game Valentine is
still pursuing history he just had a
six-inch blade shoved through his gut
he's not Agent Smith there is he Hester
survives so much bull fear that I'm just
adding 15 cents she says you mother
mother
discount Elrond just little fingers not
logan lerman it's true you will be okay
that girl really botched that murder
attempt
that's what maybe she was an engine
traction it ah yes the people who hate
traction my guess is that this is the
movies turn for people who were against
these mobile attack cities that use
massive metal traction belts to move
around but antique traction it just
sounds like you love spinning out the
mud or holding footraces on a track made
of grease then why do they hide behind
the shield while holding their resources
no clue I don't even know what a shield
wall is or what resources they're hiding
and the movie doesn't seem to have any
interest in telling me either
how elitist is the London Museum to have
three different classes of apprentices
he survived because he landed on a giant
pile of potpourri to get on that City I
had one shot at Valentine wait what you
were trying to get all in the city the
entire opening of this movie was us
watching history trying not to get
captured by the city that is Valentine
the great archeologist fatty of
Allentown and the Last Crusade suit I'm
more talking
it's like Jon Snow and your grip alone
together in the snow only somehow more
boring first we'll kill you before
hunger sure but poison and dysentery
will kill you before thirst so is the
post-apocalyptic films favorite treat
from zombie land to wall-e
which are also to much better movies I'd
rather be watching them I like the quiet
I grew up with the sound of engines I've
never known anything else so you two are
opposites then because nothing up until
now is suggested you were any kind of
odd couple
I thought you wanted to be an aviator
whities then my parents died and I found
this old film called The Aviator about
some guy who tried to have sex with a
lead singer of no doubt and then just
holed himself up in a hotel
for a while I think he drank his own
urine - then I just lost interest and
developed a taste for 90s cop walk we're
not gonna tell each other our sad
stories okay but you are legit ripping
off Jerry Maguire here 10 seconds a
flashback dream so useless I almost
thought of a word for it but then it
faded from memory what the hell is
southies
movie is 85% question-and-answer you
wouldn't want a man I haven't seen a
film trust so hard to be a Terry Gilliam
film and fails since the Brothers Grimm
that's gonna leave a scar if I see a
bitter golf lady she's hot
why would he do that to Tom because he
gotten away billboard of the villains
agenda conveniently pops up when the
villains daughter needs to see the truth
there's no way there's a way the same
cannot be said for this movie look the
way this can graboid machine has been
moving this room should be rocking so
hard that no one would ever think of
knocking but instead it's just calm
level and almost like it's not inside a
moving bug machine I was 8 years old I'm
a mother died even though Hester said
she had no interest in sharing her life
story with Tom and he has done zero
since to get on her good side
and has in fact made things so much
worse she's now comfortable enough to
start sharing her life story the last of
the Lazarus Brigade yay I'm gonna have
to look up later and still not be able
to understand this movie yeah well I'm
sure much of this will be explained in
the sequels seats I didn't know this was
part of the DCE you hope Hester and Tom
find the mother boxes before discount
Ghost Rider does well considering you've
been a real towards me and I haven't
been much better to you and we have zero
chemistry and I think I'll stick around
and go through this with you because
we're clearly meant to be together
time to check out folks oh god he's a
bad guy said no one who has ever seen a
movie before 11 cuts in 10 seconds
that's a modern action scene for him
dodging CGI is hard man oh you goddamn
it enough with the Jesus jumps also I
would bring up Hester's leg injury but
clearly the movie has forgotten about it
sudden red flying contraption ex machina
yeah
if Fang had that in our back pocket the
whole time why didn't she just rescue
Hester and Tom as soon as they got there
[Music]
strike saved my life oh god another
flashback should this maybe have been
two movies man I would rather dot I
think he had a family at once yeah I by
listening do you tell this long-ass
story so we'll just go ahead and add
Frankenstein to the list of other movies
mortal engines has picked apart and
added to its overly complex narrative
structure perfect reenactment of the
breakup of my first relationship where
we got have you heard it's a cat's
cradle meanwhile on two characters I
forgot existed and don't give to it's
about what temperate seas they are doing
in that church has nothing to do with
God you could say this about a lot of
churches honestly but I get your point
not bad you've done this before yeah and
I thought the ridiculous divert a flock
point and bumblebee couldn't be outdone
anytime soon but here we are with Tom's
childhood dreams of being an aviator
conveniently coming into play that
ballsack looking thing as a discount
Cloud City and discount Lando Calrissian
seriously this movie isn't even trying
to hide it anymore hey you just took
that guy from Twilight it's been this
she doesn't care just dead I once said
this exact same thing to my American
history professor in college I then got
pulled over by the cops and they found
two bags of cocaine under my passenger
seat I would like to say that it was my
history professor teaching me some kind
of lesson but no what's my cocaine
that's what you get for living near that
much helium I don't even know how you
got that much helium by the way but
that's what you get I would be a lot
more invested in this fight if I had any
clue what shrikes abilities and/or
powers are he appears to be beating ass
but I don't know why the ship is still
intact
it's a miracle of screenwriting Jesus
lady you've known it for two days yes
since that ends up containing the key I
want to point out that this movie's
resolution hinges on Tom helping Hester
Hester falling in love with Tom and
trike being freed from prison by
Valentine's so he could hunt down Hester
realize she's in love with Tom and give
this back to her well Shrike is dead
and I'm super sad about it let me just
tell you how upset across the centuries
traction cities have attempted to breach
the wall really because we haven't seen
evidence of this once all we've seen so
far is a
city trying to take down a mining
facility other than that this whole city
on wheels part of the story has been
borderline irrelevant we strike first
this is a very Star Wars moment we
strike first before the terrible new
death weapon can get here and murder us
this movie is all the Star Wars and
while they power up this Death Star here
I have to point out that they haven't
even test-fired this thing once at least
grand moff tarkin blew up Alderaan to
make sure it was working she wants time
to wait but he is not Tom Waits
he is Tom keeps walking what John what
have they done V for Vendetta did a
whole television broadcast about this
attack and the new buhdeuce a weapon it
was everywhere how did you miss it well
I thank Christ she saw this girl praying
and decided to walk over and eavesdrop
because otherwise game over man
now treats her name is Twix you everyone
we care about survive thank goodness
the crash drive my mother gave it to me
that's great no but you still have to
find a way onto London and then into the
church and through the guard to get the
key in the machine to shut it down
I realize this will happen but it
doesn't make it any less stupid where's
Tom ya better pick out a cool aviator
jacket there's a timetable currently
once we go in there's no going back
really you can't just go back out it's
not a force field on that city is there
this seems like terrible dialog designed
to raise the tension I would like to
think tom is now regretting those wasted
seconds picking out the jacket but he
probably doesn't think Tom I know trust
me you'll know just tell her what the
signal is she went toe-to-toe with
Shrike earlier and this guy's just a
government official she should be dead
in his ass instantly firing will
commence in 45 seconds it's always nice
how these doomsday machines let you know
how much time is left before they kill
you Tim
why just had to take it down to one
didn't you did you learn nothing from
Galaxy Quest also she's the hero because
her mother bequeathed her a flash drive
I guess it's not whether you are
bequeathed the flash drive it's whether
or not you choose to use that bequeath
flash drive between look at time flying
the plane by himself you could say he's
flying solo the person who I met for the
first time a few days ago but somehow
able to recognize his voice in the
moment of crisis such as this and will
kill you will why haven't you already
let your guard down the movie could have
ended just fine but no we have to do
this extension this ship escapes certain
death so many times in ways I filed a
complaint with a screenwriters guild
they are a little busy at the moment but
I'm sure I'll hear back eventually he
died we get it I spent so much CG money
and time on this extended crash sequence
I'm coming with you great what was your
name again try not to rip it open
because it makes a very handy storage
case for your tools until you need them
again mr. ballantine
billions of people just living out their
lives oblivious an innate desperation
they turn to a man they didn't fully
understand
we should go
[Music]
that way those tracks at south
now twigs Oh without further ado I give
you the candy Lynam I have to warn you
I've heard relationships based on
intense experiences never work quad
captain no way that would be enough to
make me self-pollinate threw up in my
mouth a little bit this is my paint
stick you cling to the past I think
you're a sexist misogynist dinosaur a
relic of the Cold War I am good